[Music]
and food for the poor news hey I like
poor food submitted by buzz off Light
beer so funny oh that's like a Buzz
Lightyear right but then buzz off buzzed
off Light beer okay a city in Brazil has
drawn criticism after creating mystery
food pellets to feed the poor miss gee
mystery food pellet mystery is it dead
people's body that they reconstitute it
depends and they feed to you have you
guys seen that movie
we're like the world froze over and
they're stopped my treat movie no the
Train dream yeah yeah that is the really
I think director Korean I think it's a
collaboration you know what's the name
of it called
what do you stop train to Pusan movie no
100 it's Korean people behind it it's
pretty good the world ended and it's
frozen frozen and everyone that's still
surviving is now on a train that just
travels infinitely around the world and
it's the only way they can survive but
in it's like a it's like a kiss a cast
of cases but it's like a classes right
so the rich people whatever live in the
front of the train and they have like
puppet sushi and flowers and like
biodomes it's like in real life and the
one in the back they live like in
poverty and they just felt like they
there felt like these these gel these
jelly squares and nobody knew it was it
was just their ration honest with eat so
basically the poor people start taking
over and moving towards the front of
train and then they go to a factory
where they make the jellies and just
watch it and it's nasty things that's
all you're gonna do you think this nasty
thing so is that what it is yeah okay so
there's this project called food for
everyone we're making hell it's called
Elemento and lamento so fishermen in
Brazil this one city right Sao Paulo is
that work honey about this
Sao Paulo I
I think so maybe so anyways so then um
they are saying that this is made out of
the dehydrated leftovers of food from
commercial processing that industry that
are close to expiring or out of market
standard so that's what they're making
these food pellets okay
and so so meat scraps what is it like
dog food like pellets pretty much it's
like spear it seems like so this is what
it looks like oh my goodness this is
what they're trying to feed the poor out
there and so one has a cute little rivet
on it I know it's like [ __ ] I'm making
you better what is it wait what is that
white yes it's a great [ __ ] I didn't
eat pellets feeding them they don't even
say what does it taste like they don't
tell you what is in it at all that's the
only description that they give oh look
at the coverage in my cheeto powder does
if if that should taste like those
cheese puffs mhm and it was made out of
cricket dick and no one told me about it
I be down hmm
it's like Soylent so is this the
difference between like someone not
having a meal or having a meal cuz if
that's the case I'm done eating anything
oh yeah a trash can I just don't like
help me make it impels it looks like
don't that's the thing so keep its
decorating yeah exactly making it to a
hotdog form just like normal you know no
sausage that's what you're supposed to
do with scraps yeah so the issue here is
that just because someone is poor it
doesn't mean that they don't have the
right to real healthy whole foods like
fruits vegetables cultural cultural
staples and not just supplements that
are dried or juice into a portable
affordable packaging is this a business
doing this or is this like a
government-funded thing and this is
their rations I would not trust a lot
anymore this is a government Wow I wish
there could be a rule in this world that
you are fine based on the waste that you
throw away depending on what it is
because I'm in charge on a personal
level or on like like supermarket level
Mercia level distributing
I would say on both because like it's
just so much food man like it's crazy
how much because they wouldn't eat it
would force you to really realize number
one pop people will probably lose a lot
of weight too because it teaches you not
to eat in excess in terms of light you
eat for what the purpose is and not just
to eat whatever and then toss it out
that's why I have the very unpopular
opinion here of like how I don't like
Chipotle cuz they gave us too much food
like I end up wasting a lot of it and I
try buying less but it's still so much
and then I don't not only that but every
time I go shopping in the grocery store
I'm always like [ __ ] I want this thing
but I don't want the whole package it
comes with like I wish they would ration
it smaller to share maybe they should
come out with a small medium large
option I really see I always know
everything I know that's why I feel
horrible like I know I caused you to
just cut that you Paulie breed on half
eat it one now and they the part lighter
I never have leftovers I hate leftover
so I eat everything on the spot even
when you're just like dying full I just
eat the whole thing
yeah me too that's why I was sick this
whole weekend cuz I know I shouldn't
have eaten all that damn food at
Smorgasburg but I ate everything anyways
so I've had diarrhea for four days yeah
that sounds like cool like it makes me
feel but doesn't eat either don't but
I'm saying like KP will eat my leftovers
if I don't finish and then I won't feel
as bad cuz I'm that way so what are
people gonna do for jobs well yeah I
mean like if we can't have that much
food and stuff mmm like restaurants and
businesses and I think restaurants can
still function but there's a proper way
to do it in a proper way not to and it's
just like there's no regulation for it
it's just like you buy whatever toss out
whatever there's like a but it's hard
though I don't even know how to go about
that I'm just like throwing suggestions
there so I just wish that the world
wasn't so that the word Lydia is like
people just looking at me like thank you
barely speaks English dude I know she
turned and looked at me I'm like Jeana
you think so I for breakfast you know
it's called a Apple peace be
I thought let's call a player Thank You
Gina I really appreciate that litigants
isn't like they just they're sooo crazy
like how Americans just to everyone for
everything yeah and like that's why
restaurants can't give away food to
homeless people because if they get sick
then they can sue you like that and that
[ __ ] sucks it's like well now we just
are thrown away yeah I'm gonna blow your
mind real quick okay okay do it I don't
know okay I'm gonna do something really
homeless right now because homeless
people always pull out a dollar right
and they always explain to you like the
Illuminati and all that [ __ ] but this is
the reason why we waste so much food I'm
gonna do a magic trick if you think
about it right what is a restaurant a
restaurant is a business what is a farm
it's a business all these things are
businesses in order to survive natural
resources and things like that
are converted into dollar dollar value
right and in order for us and this is
the same with the Amazon the jungles the
trees and all those things in order for
us to keep status quo keep things going
fishing in the ocean all those things we
need to turn profits we need to do
better than last year there's more
people on this earth than ever was
before they need to be fed but not only
that we need to give them choices they
can't just have fish they gotta have
fish beef chicken pork all kinds of [ __ ]
we need to keep doing more and more and
more to match the tastes because people
get bored of the same hamburger now you
gotta have a hamburger with a chicken
patty
now you gotta have this plus a [ __ ]
layer of cheese you got to keep pushing
the boundaries because it's all about
the business side of things once it
turns into numbers that's when [ __ ] gets
[ __ ] up because it's not a treat it's
not an animal it's a [ __ ]
number damn it Joe you played me dude
you pulled that dollar out and I was
like oh he's gonna do a [ __ ] magic
trick and then you
but he does nothing better and you
tweeted a really good magic trick but
the sad part is what we gonna do
no it's a big [ __ ] system capitalism
lazy because you're not selling come on
you know I'm investing into crypto
Chrissie and we're gonna take down the
[ __ ] banks yeah so but so for
me like I feel like that is a step
forward towards it would have taken me
scraps and they're making these little
pellets and yes the form isn't I guess
traditional and it doesn't look
presentable but to me like it depends I
guess it also depends on how poor you
are if I didn't have a meal I would
rather eat dog food or pellets or
whatever then to not having me I agree
with you I mean I feel like this is at
least a solution but it's just that a
lot of people are against it because of
that are the poor people themselves
against it or is it like other people
that feel guilty like oh my god how can
you feed back to them and the poor
people are like mmm what's the poor
people that are rou know I feel like
it's the guilty yeah they're guilty
people yeah cuz I would it would suck if
like let's say I'm over here right I'm
in this like small remote Korean village
I'm starving to death and they're
looking at the salivate we were gonna
give this to you but people say that
you're above this [ __ ] porridge out
of that [ __ ] dirty it to me puts a
couple of slices of kimchi in there
season it mm-hmm
when you see those commercials with the
with the kids and the flies all over
them do you think they're say I'm gonna
eat that just give me whatever right and
then um what about no no I'll just - go
that's the sound of this brings blanket
out your mouth makes the crazy
I started okay well this is Libby
explain my thought process like my most
favorite brain in the world I got really
mmm because I started saying Bologna hot
dogs
spam all the like that's so unhealthy
meat Vienna sausages whatever I give
them shoutouts because that [ __ ] was my
childhood yeah it's poor people meet
everyone knows they make it out of the
sludge okay like hot dogs and all those
things meat processing plants
you have these machines that cut all the
stuff right there is just sludge it
looks like snot they get all that and
then they ship them over to these plants
to make fake meat with and I don't know
why couldn't they do that with that yeah
and put it into meat shapes like that
fake rib shape I think they're also
they're making it based on nutrition too
though I think those pellets they you
said they had vegetables everything so
they don't say what is in it they're
just saying that it's like the throw
away [ __ ] from the commercial processing
industry but they do mention that they
they have all the nutrients that are
healthy person the person needs
including protein vitamins and minerals
yeah there's storage solutions so it's
dehydrated which is missing last longer
and it's gonna weigh less so if they
have to ship it ship a canned sausages
because of the water weight it's gonna
be way more expensive so it's gonna cost
more money to ship the food this is all
dehydrate so it's gonna cost way less -
how hard is it to turn it into a teddy
bear shape it might be hard because now
that's an additional cost that they have
to get this machine and people to manage
the machine what I don't know the
pellets but packaged it differently
because if you put it in a potato chip
bag it just looks like mmm I mean they
tried with the ribbon but that's their
fault
[ __ ] man presents better than that [ __ ]
what and it's only one of them has a
ribbon around like a karate that should
does kind of look like kidney stones oh
yeah or looks like somebody's to film
here it looks like popcorn really big
mini brandished it I'm starving give a
[ __ ]
hope you guys enjoyed that episode of JK
news make sure to stay connected because
we're constantly updating our social
media so follow us at JK films for
Instagram and at JK films for Twitter to
watch more videos click right over here
[Music]